Michael Ovitz is at the table this
morning he rose from working in a
mailroom to become a super agent
representing some of Hollywood's biggest
stars ov it's co-founded Creative
Artists Agency a dominating force in the
talent agent business he helped shape
the careers have listened to this roster
Steven Spielberg Meryl Streep Bill
Murray and David Letterman he is also
the agent behind classic movies like
Jurassic Park ghostbusters Schindler's
List and Rain Man his new memoir is
called who is Michael Ovitz in that CAA
read Michael we should mention that
although he's no longer part of CAA I
have to tell you that I am a CA girl
very very proud to be represented by and
so we begin Michael Ovitz
there's always full disclosure yeah I
like that transparency yes yes yes I
mean I was very fascinated by your book
because you were really at one point
considered powerful the most feared and
most hated now I know nobody likes to be
called the most hated but were you okay
with being called the most powerful and
the most feared and what role did you
play in any of those characterizations
of yourself
well you said it perfectly Gail it was a
role made a role I was a role I played a
role I made a decision that the book had
to stop with me we had 1,400 clients
there were a lot of executives in the
company and somebody had to make the
trains run on time so the decision was
made to go out and to create a someone
who dealt with Authority and was
interested in getting things done that
does not always make for a popular
camper no I was very surprised to
Michael and how candid you were you
actually named names
you took numbers you also talked about
the mistakes you've made you say this
you always wanted to make clients think
they're your friends but remember they
are not your friends they're your
clients and in the end the clients were
loyal and the friends betrayed you you
named the friends who betrayed you but
people could say you also did your fair
share of betraying too
I think that's fair I think that in the
course of doing what I did it's
impossible to please everybody all the
time when you but it's more Michael than
pleasing everybody you you did some
things on both sides though that people
could say we're ruthless
that were ambitious and were just
outright wrong unequivocally we went out
to win yeah and when you go out to win
you make certain sacrifices and it's not
always pleasant when you go out to win
but winning at all costs was something
that was critical to me I thought when
the interesting things to that was the
passion behind what you were doing
winning at all costs but also your four
commandments which any good leader has a
set of values that gets communicated all
the time throughout the company number
one never lie right
number two return every call by the end
of the day number three follow up don't
leave people guessing and every phone
desk when it's a bore the message
communicate talk about that well if we
were in a business of communication and
if one of the things that was prevalent
in the agency business before we got
into it was this concept of not telling
the truth knowledge is power and a lot
of people thought they could have power
by telling things that weren't true
flattery flattery getting into
conversations with people and saying
things that you knew weren't true you
barbra streisand called you and started
complaining about not getting equal pay
but that they weren't treating women
fairly and what did you say to her well
I actually thought she was right which
was interesting but I probably had run
out of patience by that time but don't
you also say Mike she's no longer that
the young boys are no longer I had a 15
year old son at the time and she wasn't
on the list of who they were talking
about that didn't that did not detract
from her talent she was just moving to a
different demographic graphic and they
fired her being your most ruthless was
that you doing it or the role and how
did you know who was which well you get
confused because you start to play that
role and you become that person and we I
was in a position where we were in a
service business and our assets walked
out the door every night and those
assets were the agents that worked in
the company and the clients that we all
represented in order to be able to keep
the peace and keep the trains running on
time it was very important to create an
invincible chain with no weak link in it
and
no weak link turned out to be the weak
link what kind of toll does that take it
took a big toll on me it's why I wrote
this book ten years yeah write this book
I see why it took ten years you talk
about the Disney deal with Michael
Eisner who was your very good friend I
mean it was so shocking when Eisner and
Ovitz were no longer talking because you
said it was the biggest mistake of your
life you feel that Michael Eisner really
betrayed you at that particular time he
brought you into under one circumstance
and then it ended up something else well
I I lived with Michael in his hospital
room after he had had an aqua heart
attack and I was there every day every
night for seven straight days his wife
and my wife and I were very friendly I
loved them like a brother loved his
family I was shocked when I walked into
his house to meet the two other senior
executives that were supposed to be
reporting to me and they said they
wouldn't report to me and we're getting
he didn't back me up we're gonna have to
leave that on a cliff that's right I'm
gonna have to tell Michael of us that we
got to go we gotta go we're just getting
started
no thanks who is Michael Ovitz goes on
sale tomorrow you're watching CBS this
morning we'll be right back